COUNTRIES IN THOSEIA
T
WITH
TH TO DISC
REGENERAWE
AR
R TIA REGIONANR SUPR
NO WLD
TARGETING THE GEY?E NORTASE TRYS
CING AHA THE UKRAINIAN
FORCGROUNDS THOUE D LOOK AER
STRATEGICALLY FOR JUST AO
BIDO.EN'TUCCEEDED IN IS.
THOUGH.S STILL PRETTYERE.
WH TO RE
MID-JUNE, A L CAGN
IF THE UKRAINIANS HAVEN'T
RECEIVEDUFENES BY  MEANSSTEMS F
TES, SLLGH MARS SYSTEM WHICH HAR
THEY B
D  RSIFORCES.
THERE'S NO LONRATEGY
GIVETHE SUPPORT.WHEN SUMMER'S E
FORCES, PRESIDENT XI HAS HIS  A
O ASSISTSIA, AND YOU  TSEES ARE
MIUKRAINE.UNITED STATES NEEDS TT
HE KIND THEY CAN U
TO E THE RUSSIANS NOW
THE SUMMER.
>> BECAUSE AYOSAATRSOF,
SOON FAR IS NO
YOU SEE THNTO THE SD  EN SO
S TO B OEERGAT GETTING IT ALSOO?
>> BOTH POINTS
TO BEMI, AND
AND THRU NOWGINNING TO TARGET T
INFRASTU
EQENRIOE'RE GOING
MO
IT IN.
E LONGER WE DELAY ANCE EMENT.
TH ARE REAY WIINN  P
GOING TO -- PPEN TIGY IF
AT'S THE
WE'RQUITE SURE WHAT THE STRATEGH
WANT RA RATEGY
TEH  IN THE PIPELINEO MAKE T
INSTEAD WHAT WE'RE GOING TO EN
H ISR
BA AORTH ANDN
E AGAINST THYTHING'S GOING
ADE INGS, BU NOT  RIGHT SOO
EN IUKRAINIA
U. IG TOURT ERLI IS.TSIT  UKRAIE
TH CONFL
THAN WHAT  ALREA
NI
THEENAL
WHAT IS VERSATRIGHT NO THE WHIT
HOUS WIT, AB
TO
T
RUSSECTHEY'RE KI T RE
OR IS IT TIMR THATELL, THAT'S E
NOT RESO YET INSIDE THE
USE A TACTN,E EVERYTHING.
T  I NUCLEAR WEAPO, AYO KILL PPG
LLO RED BECAUS GOING
R FI
ARE GOING
TO BE THE FIRSE OF
ON.
OUTH NR EFO  THE UNITED STATES
CAUSE US TOW FROM SUPPORT.
THSTE COUL TO  IU DO
TO LOSE.
D TO PUTHE POLICIESN  MAKU LOSE.
WE'VE HALFWAY IDHAN'SEAN QUITE L
NUISSO.E THE INTERN
D .E N'E MIGHT  A COUPLE OFTIL
ONAL
RE
T IA
USING THN ISATHELP, AND THE EAR
BEST WAY TO CONVINCE HIMT HELP G
INGHE U.S R EX
PUTIN'S PLAN FROM GIIN'SOE
SSIAN LEVIONAND HE'S TRYING P
HI DT  THRNG NUCLEAR W, HIN
E T RY
COMPETENT.
THNUWORK.L EVENTUALLY PRODUCE A
COMPETENT MILITA IF WE GTHE  W
IF YOU FIR GENERALS, ENOTROOPS
SOMEONE WILL FIGT W
R.NT FOR UOW
E TO SEETO BE STROH TO DTHIS.TH.
YON'AND BELIEVE THAT EVERY